foreign
what's up
hey Dave how are you great man how can
we help
well
so um I started uh investing in let's
say may 2020 so that's after covid-19
stomping the market and back then I was
living in a different country and I used
to have an apartment that I used to live
in without paying anything and so my
investment Grew From a hundred thousand
dollars to 180 000 in terms of my
original investment
um in the process in 2021 I ended up
moving to the United States and I got my
first lease end of last year in Phoenix
and I came here with the intention let's
say to buy property so I had around
let's say 120 000 in cash to use for a
down payment
um during that period of time the house
and market and the rental market has
gone up extremely high
and particularly in Phoenix
exactly and at this time
this
time
I'm finding myself
let's say a point where I have to make a
decision whether let's say to pull all
the cash that I have in the stock market
to use
either as a down payment or to pay as
much cash as possible for a property as
as things stand
um we will rent them and so um I'm
finding myself at a point where like
either like my rent is going to go up by
a certain percentage point
which might you know
well here's the problem
um you're in a hot rental market and
you're in a hot housing market in
Phoenix no pun intended it's 110 degrees
there right now but
um
you know so it you're you're damned if
you do damned if you don't in a sense
right uh so you're going to pay some
money out for housing period to to live
in Phoenix right now it is
um it's not a down Market by any stretch
of the imagination nor is it going to be
anytime soon
so
so one thing to do with that here
probably is I'm open to the idea
probably to relocate it to a little bit
of affordable Market at this time in
terms of housing okay but I think
standing like the events and market and
the house of Market here as you
mentioned like yeah it's just white hot
I mean it's just it's a wonderful market
in terms of the economy it's just
booming and so but the uh but it is it
is making housing
um rough so anyway wherever you're going
to live take your time
not two years but not two days don't get
house fever and get all hot and bothered
and pay too much for something
so go take your time analyze the market
that place the neighborhood you're
looking at work with a good real estate
agent that knows their stuff and don't
overpay don't overpay and so
um and don't pull your money out of the
market well I would about to buy the
house I would oh you would yeah it's not
it's not in oh it's not retirement money
it's not in a retirement account all
right my mood don't listen to me it's
not in a retirement account right it's
it's not so I'm just I'm going to use
all the money I get my hands on to do
this deal then
the cat the cash and the stock and the
money you got in the stock market and I
know the Market's down it's not a great
time to pull your money out but it to
John's point but right now what I'm
trying to do is just get you a house and
then get turned and get it paid off as
fast as you can you have an ability to
make money you always have and you
probably will continue to make good
money and you'll be able to work your
way right through this so you're going
to take some losses probably on that
stock market account but that's not the
end of the world go buy your house and
get you a good deal but go slow don't
get crazy don't get caught up in the
hype because the hype is about over it's
kind of slowed down out there a little
bit in a lot of places no not Phoenix
Phoenix is booming but
you know you and I had a friend the
other day that bought a house and um
the guy had it overpriced because he
thought he'd you know that he's going to
get one of these California sucker fish
coming in here to buy stuff and that's
what we call you California people that
overpay for stuff and so
um but the uh got a good deal on it but
the guy no it wasn't he bought it from
market price we have another friend same
guy he bought it for appraisal but 60
000 under asking because the guy the guy
was fishing for sucker fish he wasn't he
was looking for a sucker and he was
overpriced and our guy just said no and
they've been on the market three whole
days so the seller panicked and gave it
away